hello my name is Karen morning first we
get show let hi hello and we are going
to present Craig with a special present
from our latest sponsor which is
snorgtees snorgtees com all right ready
I'm ready ok sorry exciting drumroll
drumroll whoa did I get rego and oh look
it's a t-shirt third grade line ID no
kidding no kidding it's true I just had
a conversation with my dad about this
the other day about does anybody
actually use cursive it's funny I
thought this would be the perfect shirt
for you that does really well yeah as
nobody does Wow don't learn cursive just
write pretty very quickly okay you heard
it here Smarties dr. oh and here's mine
chin chillin to shoot
switch